I hope to encourage people one of the
things that's been painful about what
I've been doing with my wife as we've
traveled around the world for the last
number of years is to see how desperate
people are for
an encouraging word there is nothing
that people like more and need more than
to be listened to if you could Envision
a path forward out of your misery let's
say to somewhere better what would that
look like and it's not a question people
ask themselves with enough depth and
then having developed that Vision what
are the strategies that might be put in
place to make that more likely and again
not in a manipulative way but if you had
to conduct yourself in the proper manner
to bring about this desirable land or at
least to move towards it how would you
organize your behave when
now the problem with that is it leaves
you without a goal and it also leaves
empty space which you immediately have
to fill and so often people feel
disquiet because now they don't know
what to do and they miss that rush
because they're no longer pursuing
something and so it's very important to
know that positive emotion is
experienced in relationship to a valued
goal and then the question becomes well
what's the most valuable goal to pursue
what people don't understand about that
in some sense is that the purpose of
your life is not going to be happiness
sometimes it is
sometimes that will come but there will
be difficult periods in your life and
happiness won't suffice then but what
you can have in your life is an
adventure you can have an adventure
there's no doubt about that and there's
a couple of reasons for that one is you
don't know what's going to happen if you
say what you think now I don't mean in
cautiously and I don't mean
provocatively or any more than necessary
you don't know what's going to happen so
that's very adventurous but also if it's
you and your voice then it's your
adventure and if it isn't like if you're
crafting your speech or manipulating in
any way or parroting or abiding by the
dictates of the crowd
then I don't know whose Adventure you're
having but it's not yours take on some
responsibility do something for other
people you're doing something for
yourself while you're doing that even if
you don't know it for sure because
you're a community across time find a
job do your best with the customers
don't be above your job you're going to
get an entry-level job when you're a kid
or what else would you want you want to
be the boss what do you know you don't
know anything you could be the boss of
your job you know if you're working in a
grocery store you're working in a
convenience store assuming you're not
working for terrified tyrants you can be
nice to the customers you can develop
your social skills you can learn how to
handle boss employee relationship and if
you go and show yourself as competent
there'll be a trial period but if you go
show yourself as confident all sorts of
doors you didn't even know were there
will start opening like mad people have
been after me for a long time by because
I've been speaking to disaffected young
men now what a terrible thing to do that
is
thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice it's making emotional
talk about well God you know it's very
difficult to understand how demoralized
people are and certainly many young men
are in that category
and you get these casual insults these
these in cells what do they mean it's
like well these men they're they don't
know how to make themselves attractive
to women who are very picky and good for
them women like be picky that's that's
your gift man demand high standards from
your man fair enough but all these men
who are alienated it's like they're
Lonesome and and they don't know what to
do and everyone piles abuse on them
there are no shortage of women out there
who've never had a positive relationship
with anyone masculine and so they're
very they're completely unable to
discriminate between
narcissistic power and compulsion and
confident competence and so because they
can't distinguish that and they're
afraid they put all of that in the same
category which is something like the
Predator category and and that's not
good for them because well as you said
all men aren't Predators all the time
and they need to establish a
relationship with the man we all have a
tendency to drift in our weakest Place
let's say and so some people become
alcohol like some people will become
narcissistic and so on we all have our
Temptations and one of the ways we
buttress ourselves against that is by
having other people say no you there
you're not funny they're you're boring
they're you need to be reigned in and if
you deprive yourself of that that's what
happens to hyper celebrities and
dictators they deprive themselves of
that social regulation because they
forbid it and then they're then they're
in hell and sometimes they drag everyone
along with them genuine ethical virtue
it's the only source of resilience and
strength that you have and it's also the
place as far as I can tell that the
meaning that allows you to set yourself
against suffering resides you know
people talk about life and its meaning
and they say well life is meaningless
but people never mean that because if
you're in pain or you're terrified
you're overwhelmed with meaning it's
just not the kind of meaning you want
and it's not a reality you can talk
yourself out of easily and that's
particularly true pain but it can also
be true of anxiety and so the question
is is there a reliable source of meaning
that you can set against that that's the
fundamental question of life is how do
we adapt ourselves to the infinite
complexity that surrounds us what must
we become well you don't nearly think
that through I mean you don't I don't
human beings in general don't we puzzle
it out and we use all sorts of
information to do that and and some of
these more primordial experiences that
are outside the domain of strict
rationality nonetheless point is in an
in an ethical Direction and The ethic
would be you should and could be more
than you are well then the question is
how do you bring that to Earth how how
does that look when you try to embody it
day to day well I would say these and
this these are obviously not my ideas
they're very old ideas well maybe you
align yourself with truth to the degree
that you can maybe you pursue Duty maybe
you pursue the love that attaches you
appropriately to other people and you do
that because well I think you do it
because life is very very difficult life
is brutally difficult and sometimes
unbearably brutally difficult and and
you can see the progressives playing
with that notion it's warped into this
sense of victimization but it does does
reflect some understanding of the
underlying tragic reality of life and so
it's good to get that right on the table
to begin with say well you're miserable
you have your reasons and they might be
deep reasons but if you let the misery
demoralize you and make you bitter and
cynical and cowardly and make you
withdraw then first of all that's a
failure in the highest Sense on your
part and all it's going to do is make
everything worse and then you might
think well what do you have to respond
to that how do you respond to that
catastrophe and Challenge and the answer
is and this is what Rocky is telling his
son in no uncertain terms it's like
terrible as things are there's a lot
more to you than you can possibly
imagine and that if you face those
things forthrightly and with some faith
and courage then you can have the
adventure of your life and Prevail even
over catastrophe like I think people
should plan and they should develop a
vision you have to develop the vision
and then be somewhat detached from it
because it needs to be updated right and
modified you have to note when you're
being called to be more than you are and
you have to attend to that very
carefully because life is
extraordinarily difficult and to manage
it in a manner that makes it acceptable
or perhaps more than acceptable you have
to be everything you could be and so you
establish a goal then movement towards
that goal or evidence that you could
move towards that goal makes you happy
produces positive emotion whereas
evidence that the goal is invalid or
that you're blocked in some way produces
negative emotion oh I think the best
practice is to try to not lie try to
stop lying listen to your words feel
them are are they the right words do you
believe this do you believe what you're
saying is it true as far as you're
concerned and then then you might find
that you have something true to say but
you're afraid to okay then there there's
a place for integration of the Shadow
because hopefully you can be monstrous
enough
say what you believe to be true and so
that means there's a combativeness in
some sense in that and so if you can't
do that so maybe you don't say what's
true because you want to look you want
to be a Persona you want to be nice you
want to appeal to people you want to be
popular whatever whatever it is you're
pursuing yeah you're going to do it in a
manipulative way and and you subjugate
your truth to that that's not helpful
the people who need assertiveness
training are often people who are too
agreeable compassionate polite by
temperament now the problem with that is
that they let people walk all over them
because they don't stand up enough for
themselves and the consequence of that
is they get resentful and then they get
bitter and then they get conniving and
then they'll mob they'll do anything for
everyone else but they push themselves
beyond their limits and they and then
they won't even recognize the limits
because they feel well if I'm not doing
everything for you then then I'm not a
good person it's like no a good person
does a little for you like if I'm acting
properly with you say in this
conversation there's something in it for
you and there's something in it for me
right and we want that to be reciprocal
and so the cost of me bending too far in
your direction is that I'll become
bitter and resentful and conniving and
that and resentment is an unbelievable
toxic state of being that's the problem
with hate crime not translations like
who defines hate and I know the answer
to that who defines hate the people you
least want to
so you know you want hate crime
legislation you just better keep in mind
who's going to Define what constitutes
hate I I said in one of the chapters of
my books is is focused on putting your
house in order it's like well how do you
start make your bed it actually took me
quite a long time in my life before I
made my bed regularly in the morning
most of my life was in pretty good order
but that was one thing I didn't have in
order my clothes in my closet as well
all that's in order not all of it I'm
cleaning out some drawers right now but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look was like okay I'm in
my room do I like this room no it bugs
me okay why well the Pain's peeling
there and it's dusty there and the
carpet's dirty and that corner is kind
of ugly and the light there isn't very
good and my clothes closet's a mess so I
don't even like to open it
um okay that's a lot of problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it but not too
much so it the rule is
pick a problem pick a solution to it
that you know wouldn't help that you
could do that you would do so you have
to negotiate with yourself it's like oh
I won't clean up this room how do you
know I've been in here for 10 years and
I've never cleaned it up it's like well
obviously that's too big a dragon for
you would you clean one drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which I
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way